[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance on July 14th
Kellyanne Conway who 7 months ago had
denied that there had ever been any
contact about electoral meddling between
the Trump campaign and the Russians
announced quote the goalposts have been
moved
we were promised hard evidence of
systemic sustained furtive collusion in
point of fact the story of the June 9th
2016 Trump jr. vessel mitts Khayyam
meeting is all that and more the sheer
volume of information in this one threat
of the Trump campaign conspiracy with
Russia is so overwhelming that only when
viewed chronologically does it make any
sense or does it become clear that it is
in short a timeline of treason spring
2015 / The Wall Street Journal US
intelligence agencies begin to detect
conversations and quote captured Russian
government officials discussing
Associates of Donald Trump
June 3rd 2016 Trump acquaintances Rob
Goldston emails Trump jr. offering a
meeting at which Trump jr. will be
provided with quote very high-level and
sensitive information that would
incriminate Hillary as part of Russia
and its governments support for mr.
Trump 17 minutes later Trump jr. replies
if it's what you say I love it
June 7th 2016 6:14 p.m. Trump jr.
confirms the meeting June 7th 2016 9 13
p.m. three hours after the confirmation
Donald Trump gives a speech promising
revelations quote probably next Monday
about how Hillary Clinton's quote
corrupt dealings gave quote favorable
treatment to other governments including
quote the Russians June 9th 2016 4 p.m.
Trump jr. Kushner Manafort meet in Trump
Tower with Russian attorney Natalia
vessel Matz kaya reported Russian spy
Rena Achmed the publicist Goldston a pro
Putin translator and possibly others
bezel night sky are reportedly tells
Trump jr. Kushner and man afford that
she has information about illicit
donations and funding to the Clinton
campaign and the Democratic National
Committee they do not contact the eff
by June 9th 2016 4:40 p.m. 10 minutes
after the meeting ends Donald Trump
tweets mockingly about Clinton's emails
using the figures 33,000 for the first
time June 14 2016 five days after the
meeting it is revealed for the first
time that the Democratic National
Committee has been the victim of an
ongoing month-long cyber attack
documents then posted by hacker gucchy
for 2.0 July 24 2016 45 days after the
meeting Trump jr. is interviewed on CNN
and dismisses questions about whether
the Russians are trying to hurt Clinton
it's disgusting
Trump jr. says it's so phony I can't
think of bigger lies but that exactly
goes to show you what the DNC and what
the Clinton camp will do they will lie
and do anything to win July 27th 2016 48
days after the meeting at a news
conference Trump says quote Russia if
you're listening I hope you're able to
find the 30,000 emails December 18 2016
192 days after the meeting trump advisor
Kellyanne Conway asked if anyone
involved in the Trump campaign had any
contact with Russians tried to meddle
with the election answers quote
absolutely not and I discussed that with
the president-elect just last night
those conversations never happened that
is just not only inaccurate and false
but it's dangerous March 17 2017 281
days after the meeting the New York
Times asks Trump jr. if he had any
campaign related meetings with Russian
nationals none that were set up none
that I can think of at the moment
certainly none that I was representing
the campaign in any way
April 4th 2017 299 days after the
meeting Senator Charles Grassley of Iowa
writes to the Secretary of Homeland
Security asking for information about a
lobbyist who quote has been accused of
acting as an unregistered foreign agent
for Russian interests and apparently has
ties to Russian intelligence the
lobbyist is named Renat AK mentioned he
was at the meeting no later than April
30th 2000
325 days after the meeting the fact of
the Trump jr. Kushner mana fort meeting
with vessel nets kya and the others is
known to the Senate Intelligence
Committee member James Lankford of
Oklahoma says quote this meeting was
known because it was turned in in the
background checks in April actually for
Jared Kushner May 12 2007 teen 337 days
after the meeting the Trump Justice
Department settles its fraud and money
laundering case against a Russian firm
the damages sought had been two hundred
and thirty million dollars the
settlement amount was just six million
dollars the Russian firm was previs on
holdings its attorney was natalia vessel
mitts kiya the prosecution had been
begun by the man Trump fired as the New
York US Attorney Preet Bharara June 23rd
2017 379 days after the meeting Kushner
reportedly resubmits his sf-86 security
form for the second time ads only one
name to the list of his foreign contacts
that of Natalya vessel mitts kaya
approximately June 27th 2017 383 days
after the meeting
Trump attorneys mark Kassovitz and Allen
Garten are reportedly informed of the
Trump jr. email chain about the meeting
and the Trump campaign reportedly pays
fifty thousand dollars to the Law
Offices of Allen s fooder Fox he will
shortly be identified as representing
Trump jr. and per election law if he can
be paid through the campaign then by
definition he is dealing with a campaign
matter
July 8th 2017 three hundred and ninety
four days after the meeting the New York
Times reports Trump jr. Kushner and mana
Ford met with vessel mitts kaya on June
9th 2016 Trump jr. then issues a denial
claiming the meeting was about Russian
adoptions the New York Times later
reports the denial was crafted by quote
a small cadre of president Trump's
advisors huddled in a cabin aboard Air
Force One ultimately the President
signed off on a statement for Donald
Trump jr.
quote that effectively makes any effort
to conceal this truth
a White House cover-up July 9th 2017 395
days after the meeting the New York
Times now reports Trump jr. was promised
dirt on Hillary Clinton at that meeting
Trump jr. now issues a second denial
saying the meeting was supposed to be
about the Clinton campaign and dirt but
that he ended it when no supporting
evidence was provided and the subject
was changed to adoptions July 11th 2017
397 days after the meeting the New York
Times advises Trump jr. it is about to
publish his email chain he releases it
instead himself he is interviewed on Fox
News dismisses the meeting as quote such
a nothing is asked quote as far as this
incident is concerned this is all of it
and Trump jr. replies this is everything
this is everything July 12 2017 398 days
after the meeting Donald Trump speaks of
the meeting to reporters aboard Air
Force One quote I only heard about it
two or three days ago July 13 2017 399
days after the meeting Donald Trump
changes his story he tells reporters he
may have known about the meeting earlier
quote in fact maybe it was mentioned at
some point but he insists he was not
told it was about Hillary Clinton and
dirt the press secretary for Vice
President Mike Pence is then interviewed
by Fox News three times he is asked if
pence has ever met with Russians three
times he refuses to answer July 14 2017
400 days after this meeting it is
reported another Russian accompany bezel
Nats kya
he soon identifies himself as Ronnie
tock mention he is in turn identified as
a former Soviet intelligence agent
possibly continuing Russian quote asset
accused computer hacker AK mention
reportedly says vessel Nats kya brought
a folder of documents to the meeting and
he believes she left them there vessel
Nats kya in turn tells The Wall Street
Journal she was in frequent contact with
Russian officials July 16th 2017 402
after the meeting Trump attorney Jay
Sekulow asks why if it was nefarious the
Secret Service didn't prevent the
meeting of June 9th 2016 it is noted
that at that date no member of the Trump
family except Trump himself was
receiving Secret Service protection
raising the question why the Secret
Service would have vetted a meeting
Trump himself did not know about himself
or asked about himself or attend himself
we were promised hard evidence of
systemic sustained furtive collusion
said Kellyanne Conway well miss Conway
promise fulfilled your client can turn
himself in any time now
resist remove peace